How to Colonize a New Planet.
Now that scientists have discovered evidence of thousands of other planets,...
...the next question is obviously, how can we colonize them?
Keep these considerations in mind to become a colonial power of galactic proportion.
You will need: a planet in the Goldilocks zone,...
...speedy spaceships, outer space fertility,...
...man - made biospheres and terraforming.
Step 1: Target a planet in the so-called Goldilocks zone,...
...close enough to a sun so temperatures are neither too hot nor too cold but just right.
This ensures that water would be available in liquid form.
Step 2: Figure out how to get there in this lifetime.
Most planets are light-years away.
Circumventing the speed of light would be a good start.
Step 3: If possible, pick an uninhabited land.
It's much easier to colonize a new planet without any alien life forms...
...who could very well outsmart and overpower earthlings.
Renowned astrophysicist Stephen Hawking said that alien life is likely.
Step 4: Protect human fertilization.
Scientists investigating the feasibility of colonizing Mars...
...found that high levels of radiation in space would make pregnancy problematic.
And negative population growth makes a planet pretty hard to colonize.
Step 5: Build housing:...
...man - made biospheres that allow people to survive on the new planet...
...by providing closed ecological systems.
Step 6: Start terraforming:...
...changing the new planet's environment so earthlings can live outside their biospheres.
Then, try not to pollute it so soon!
Did you know?
Scientists believe that as many as half the stars in our galaxy...
...have planets that are two to ten times the size of Earth and may sustain life.